Welcome to "I'm Your Target Demographic"...
...and today we're discussing e-sports.
This video is not intended for people...
...that are familiar, know this topic inside-out,...
...but rather for folks that don't know what this means...
...or don't understand its significance.
So if you're in the first category,...
...share this video with someone in the second category.
What does the term "e-sport" mean?
It's literally short for electronic sports,...
...meaning video games that can be played competitively...
...either as an individual or as a team.
This idea of competing has existed since video games themselves have existed.
We had people playing Space Invaders to beat the high score.
Arcades were places where heroes could be made,...
...people breaking records and becoming local celebrities.
When PC gaming became popular,...
...this is where people began to play against strangers,...
...people who could be in other countries.
This launched the era of international icons,...
...teams and players that could claim to be the best in the world.
We jump forward to now.
This is not a history lesson.
There are many games that are considered e-sports...
...that have tournaments and prizes and plenty of chances for people to compete.
If you're a developer and you can find a way to make your game competitive,...
...this can extend the lifetime of the game considerably.
However, many games tout themselves as an e-sport,...
...but if they don't gain traction,...
...their competitive scene is not strong...
...and this could make or break the reputation of the game.